j'ai conscience que je suis en train de
partir de mourir que je reviendrai pas
que je ne verrai plus les miens mais en
même temps je ne suis pas triste
Cathy
alors Cathy cadane vous êtes
aide-soignante depuis 30 ans la mort
fait partie de votre vie professionnelle
depuis toujours mais un jour vous êtes
foudroyés par un AVC et plongé dans un
coma profond quelques minutes plus tard
vous connaissez une expérience de mort
imminente on dit aussi
Ndef Xperience vous nous raconterez ça à
20h
[Musique]
vous êtes né à Toulouse le 15 octobre
1962 père technicien chez AZF mère
employé à la mairie et un frère plus
jeune la maison dans laquelle vous
grandissez appartient la famille depuis
deux siècles et demi et elle jouxte un
cimetière
alors même si vos copines refusent de
venir dormir chez vous à cause des
fantômes des revenants des feux follets
et du diable vous ça vous dérange pas du
tout ça fait partie de mon quotidien ces
gens-là sont jamais venus me voir chez
moi par la mort pas du tout absolument
pas en revanche vous êtes une petite
fille pleine de vie sportive un peu
garçon manqué j'étais plus à l'aise en
pantalon et un short et en tennis comme
jupe alors à 18 ans vous avez votre bac
D et vous découvrez le monde médical à
l'adolescence à travers deux grandes
tentes infirmières en psychiatrie à
Toulouse et après le bac donc vous
décidez de vous lancer dans la carrière
alors le premier contact avec la mort
vous vous en souvenez comme c'était hier
c'était un jeudi
à 7h30 du matin et on vous dit il faut
aller voir le mort et là vous êtes
terrorisé à l'idée de voir quelqu'un de
mort vous avez 19 ans mais en fait vous
découvrez que le visage est assez serein
et par chance la personne en question
était pas complètement froide tout à
fait et effectivement quelque part ça
m'a un petit peu rassuré et moi-même
impressionné la gestion d'un mort le
déshabillage la toilette l'obturation
des orifices on croise les mains sur le
ventre ça fait partie de notre tâche la
nuit suivante
Cathy et la nuit qui a suivi
effectivement j'ai pas très bien dormi
j'ai cauchemardé j'ai sans arrêt revu
cette personne devant mes yeux c'est
particulier c'est glauque donc après un
passage dans une clinique psychiatrique
dans un poste de nuit vous vous
retrouvez dans une clinique
médico-chirurgicale classique et là
et là
le 26 août 2000 vous êtes en vacances
chez des amis dans un petit village des
Pyrénées-Orientales faites du bricolage
le soir vous avez la tête farci par le
bruit des perceuses et des scie sauteurs
vous sortez du garage vous travaillez
pour fumer une cigarette et au moment où
vous allumez votre cigarette votre corps
s'effondre comme une poupée de chiffon
je tombe et je prends ma main je touche
ce côté-ci je sens et je fais ça et là
je sens plus et je me dis ben tu es en
train de faire un AVC alors évidemment
les pompiers les médecins le SAMU et on
vous amène en hélicoptère à Perpignan et
c'est pendant le transfert en
hélicoptère à Perpignan que vous faites
une expérience donc de mort imminente
une NDE alors vous êtes dans
l'hélicoptère mais vous planez en fait
je plane oui effectivement
et en fait je
n'ai plus du tout la sensation de mon
enveloppe corporelle vous êtes évanes
comme on dit en physique une sublimation
oui voilà je suis quelque chose qui
reçoit et qui perçoit des milliers
d'informations à la seconde et
c'est extraordinaire et en même temps
je n'ai je ne suis pas du tout
impressionnée je n'ai absolument pas
peur
général d'amour universel quoi oui
quelque chose de d'infini quelque chose
d'extraordinaire alors soudain vous
voyez une ligne blanche se dessinait
devant vous elle passe entre vos jambes
elle s'étend jusqu'à l'infini c'est très
très lumineux absolument pas aveuglant
absolument pas dérangeant c'est
[Musique]
c'est même peut-être un petit peu
rassurant quelque part de voir cette
ligne et là une règle vous semble
évidente si vous mettez le pied droit à
gauche vous partez de suite j'ai
conscience que je suis en train de
partir de mourir que je reviendrai pas
que je ne verrai plus les miennes mais
en même temps je ne suis pas triste je
n'ai aucun regret je n'ai aucun roman et
c'est ce qui m'a le plus marqué alors au
bout de cette ligne blanche il y a un
halo blanc et dans ce halo il y a une
dizaine de personnes une dizaine de
silhouettes qui vous attendent mais vous
ne savez rien ne vous ne reconnaissez
personne à ce moment là j'ai du mal à
distinguer effectivement si ce sont des
hommes ou des femmes la certitude que
j'ai à ce moment-là c'est que ces
gens-là sont là pour m'accueillir
heureux donc c'est quelque chose qui
m'attire en fait donc je vais je
m'approche de ce halo lumineux et de ces
personnes qui connaissent ma vie sur le
bout des doigts qui connaissent tout de
moi ça m'attire parce qu'en plus ce sont
des gens qui sont par rapport à moi qui
sont bienveillants qui m'attendent qui
sont là uniquement pour moi et en même
temps vous savez que si vous approchez
trop vous allez atteindre le point de
non retour quoi oui je que c'est la fin
mais c'est tellement confortable et
agréable en fait et là vous entendez une
femme qui vous dit on ne te veut pas on
ne te veut pas et je vais te montrer
pourquoi et là vous voyez les deux
jeunes fils d'un ami d'enfants qui
pleurent sur votre ton je vois ces deux
enfants ils sont extrêmement malheureux
pour
quelque part je me dis je peux pas aller
laisser dans cet état là vous décidez de
faire marche arrière vous revenez dans
votre enveloppe corporelle et à ce
moment-là les bruits les cris la lumière
vous reviennent c'est très agressif je
me demande de ce qui se passe parce
qu'on me crie dans les oreilles on m'a
découpé mes vêtements aux ciseaux et je
me dis que mais qu'est-ce que tu fais là
quoi mais pourquoi tu es revenu quoi
pourquoi tu es là votre expérience de
mort imminente a duré deux heures quand
même un lendemain vous êtes rapatrier à
Toulouse vous avez le côté gauche
entièrement paralysé c'est incapable de
parler ou de marcher là commence la
rééducation
vous dites si ta vie c'est d'être assise
dans un fauteuil en train de t'exprimer
en écrivant sur une ardoise il aurait
mieux valu rester là-bas c'est sûr je me
suis dit 38 ans il te reste quand même
pas mal de vie bon chemin à faire
effectivement si ça doit être ça je ne
supporterai pas c'est tellement mieux
là-bas que tu vas te débrouiller pour y
retourner au suicide à ce moment-là bien
sûr j'ai calculé j'ai
réfléchi à la façon dont chez ma mère il
y a un fusil dont je pouvais faire
tomber le fusil avec un balai le coin
c'est entre les jambes me poser la tête
comme ça dessus et partir définitivement
et ne pas me rater alors par chance
votre rééducation ne durera que huit
mois et un an après vous reprenez le
travail en réanimation alors ce qui est
formidable maintenant c'est comme vous
avez plus peur de la mort vous expliquer
à vos patients laissez-vous aller c'est
que du bonheur quoi
effectivement quand je me retrouve avec
eux et que il y a plus rien à faire que
c'est vraiment la fin que voilà je vous
dis pas non plus à tout le monde je dis
ben écoutez allez-y il y a des gens qui
vous attendent et c'est pas le néant il
y a autre chose d'autre et c'est
tellement mieux que ce qu'on vit ici-bas
que lâcher prise alors avec cette
expérience Cathy vous n'êtes pas devenu
croyante pour autant mais vous savez
qu'il y a quelque chose après la mort
qui n'a rien à voir avec la religion en
fait vous êtes intime aujourd'hui
exactement je crois à quelque chose
effectivement c'est sûr je mettrai ma
main au fait ma tête à couper il y a
autre chose et il y a quelque chose mais
pas de la façon dont on me l'a appris il
y a pas un grand barbu dans le ciel sur
un nuage mais vous affirmez qu'il y a
autre chose après la mort bien sûr alors
Michel vous y croyez pas
non
moi j'ai plusieurs arguments d'abord
j'ai fait un infarctus j'ai eu droit
aussi à l'hélicoptère j'ai fait un AVC
j'ai eu droit aussi à ce que vous avez
raconté il se fait que il y a trois mois
j'ai perdu ma compagne un cancer de 13
ans donc les histoires qui nous
racontent que on vit la mort de son
vivant je crois pas une seconde
il y a une explication physiologique à
ces choses là on a un corps qui produit
naturellement de la morphine on peut du
fait d'être soignante vous le savez que
les médecins eux-mêmes vous ont
probablement injecté des substances pour
vous calmer qui sont des substances d'un
type hallucinogène c'est la même texture
que les rêves ce que vous avez vécu ce
sont
ce que vous rêvez ne prouve rien d'autre
du réel qu'un fonctionnement de votre
cerveau donc je ne nie pas ce que vous
avez expérimenté en revanche je me
permets de ne pas avoir la lecture que
vous proposez la mort ça existe après la
mort il n'y a plus rien on en revient
pas et voilà une réponse Cathy
je quand j'en parle je dis que je me
suis approchée de l'amour je dis pas que
j'ai été dans la mort si j'avais été
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la mort
effectivement je ne serai pas là
aujourd'hui je n'en saurai pas tout à
l'heure que vous vous en servez
aujourd'hui pour dire à des gens qui
sont en situation de mourir qu'il ne
faut pas avoir peur oui mais pas avoir
peur de quoi de pas parce que les gens
quand moi les patients que je rencontre
bien sûr j'ai tenu la main à une
collègue de travail qui est parti avec
qui j'ai travaillé pendant plus de 12
ans c'est pas rien non plus mais mon
père est mort dans mes bras aussi
j'étais présent on projette ce fantasme
alors moi mon fantasme il est pas
religieux la réalité elle est athée et
on voit pas forcément le réel de la même
manière moi je l'ai malheureusement vu
et puis après on peut ne pas vouloir le
voir le réel donc on invente des choses
du genre je suis mort mais je suis
revenu il y a quand même une espèce de
de d'impossibilité logique rationnelle
de dire je suis mort je suis revenu je
suis vivant à nouveau merci de votre
témoignage qu'a dit merci beaucoup et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu